Привіт! Мене звати Євген Клопотенко.
Я є кулінарним експертом і співзасновником ресторану української кухні «100 років тому вперед».
Коли я відкривав ресторан, я чітко розумів, що мені не вистачає людей, з якими можна працювати.
Знайти гарного, професійного кухаря, офіціанта
чи менеджера — це величезна проблема.
Я провів майже 100 співбесід для того,
щоб відібрати лише 2 кухарів.
І ця проблема є не лише в мене,
а є проблемою на загальнонаціональному рівні
І я зрозумів, що мені треба йти до закладів профосвіти
для того, щоб там знайти класних працівників.
І я так і зробив!
Я пішов до одного закладу, знайшов 50 кухарів
і з них вибрав 15 найкращих.
Так, зараз у моєму ресторані працює 15 кращих кухарів, які закінчили заклад профосвіти.
Ось — Костянтин. Йому 20 років і він вже працює
су-шефом в моєму ресторані.
Він отримує конкурентну заробітну платню,
а найголовніше те, що він працює
за спеціальністю, про яку завжди мріяв.
Він не хотів бути юристом, економістом або іншим фахівцем. Він завжди хотів бути кухарем.
Люди з професійною освітою роблять
життя інших кращим і комфортнішим.
Я особисто отримую задоволення,
коли виходжу до людей та чую їхнє
“Дякую, Женя, за цю приємну та смачну страву”.
Давайте закріпимо основні переваги профосвіти.
По-перше, це дуже швидко.
Навчання може тривати від 6 місяців до 3-х років.
По-друге, під час навчання ви можете вже працювати та отримувати заробітну платню.
По-третє, навчання є безкоштовним
і надається гуртожиток.
Найголовніше — ви можете працювати
на роботі своєї мрії.
До закладу профтехосвіти можна вступати
після 9-го або 11-го класу.
Але, якщо ви вже не навчаєтеся в школі
й бажаєте підвищити кваліфікацію
або отримати нову професію,
то, будь ласка, також вступайте.
На перший погляд вам може здатися, що профтехосвіта застаріла і нічого в ній не змінюється.
Але це зовсім не так.
Тому що країна вже запустила реформу
та почала залучати експертів для її зміни.
Наприклад, особисто я взявся за кухарів і вже зараз ми змінюємо систему кухарського навчання.
Я хочу, щоб ви розуміли, що без робітничих професій Україна просто зупиниться.
Тому ви потрібні країні.
Я впевнений, що класні робітники завжди
матимуть роботу та можливість розвиватися.
Не бійтеся перетворити ваш талант
у справжню професію!
Вступайте до профтеху!